[Musik]
im moment haben
notruf oder häuslicher gewalt us-bericht
bühne aus zu finden wollte sich
weiterentwickeln
[Musik]
die mission amerika nun wird er polizist
in new orleans eine stadt in der die
kriminalität zwar zurück geht die aber
immer noch zu den gefährlichsten der usa
zählt an jedem dritten tag wird hier
jemand getötet
[Musik]
an der polizeiakademie in new orleans
geht es heute lockerer zu als sonst
es ist der letzte schultag
diese beginnt mit einer tradition einem
lauf der die zusammengehörigkeit
festigen soll
sprecht bühler reist er für die
aufnahmeprüfungen dreimal nach new
orleans und schafft er alle acht
testphasen er besitzt die greencard die
arbeitsbewilligung und eine jahrelange
berufserfahrung
er arbeitete unter anderem während fünf
jahren bei der regionalpolizei zofingen
der schritt nach new orleans ist für ihn
schnell erklärt doch zum einen ob idee
zum der linkspolitiker mitlachen und der
harmonie im augenblick der schweiz und
hier
denn schon direkt bei mir hier und da
schlafen schlafen und der als bin ich
hier
wäre als 28 wochen wurde er an der
akademie beträgt erlaubnis einzutreten
[Musik]
neu für den 35 jährigen waren vor allem
die amerikanischen gesetze und der taser
die elektroschockwaffen am härtesten war
es als er sich einen professionellen ml
kämpfer stellen musste
[Musik]
die zur analyse und stilistik sie drei
minuten
irgendwie rutschte er nicht wusste was
man bekannt und es muss keiner merkt
aber dass ich hinter sich sehr schwierig
denn ist es knapp
er erhält die polizei dienstmarke bruce
willis sie haben in etwa seine größe und
fast denselben haarschnitt der spitzname
bruce willis ist für ihn ein kompliment
die dienstmarke ein symbol seiner
leistung
[Musik]
die 34 rekruten versammeln sich ein
letztes mal für die diplomfeier ihre
familienangehörigen sind eingetroffen
unter ihnen ehefrau rachel der
polizeichef von die bürgermeisterin
bedanken sich dass sich die rekruten in
den dienst der stadt stellen
ich möchte mich auch bei den familien
für ihre unterstützung bedanken
ich verspreche wir werden euch nicht
alleine lassen
wir werden an eurer seite sein
ihr seid uns wichtig
danke fürs kommen
ich bin sehr sehr stolz
wir nannten brechbühler bruce willis da
uns seine art und leistung an den
schauspieler erinnerten
es war eine großartige erfahrung mit ihm
zu arbeiten seine verhaltensweisen
kennenzulernen und ihnen die
polizeiarbeit in den usa zu leeren
es war spannend zu sehen wie ihr die
erfahrungen aus seiner heimat an das
neue heer anpasste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die spezial auszeichnung für den besten
notendurchschnitt
[Musik]
nun ist der offiziell der klügste
polizeibeamte seiner klasse
eine auszeichnung das freut mich
[Musik]
das sind gute news aber seinen namen
haben sie falsch geschrieben
sie haben das haar vergessen
[Gelächter]
hier
polizist zu sein begeistertes er geht
gerne zur arbeit er ist interessiert und
neugierig was auf ihn zukommt klar mache
ich mir sorgen aber er ist glücklich
jeden tag arbeiten zu gehen und
glücklich zu sein mehr kann man nicht
erwarten
und der gedanke er könnte eines tages
nicht mehr nach hause kommen
ich bin auf jeden fall besorgt aber ich
nehme das leben tag für tag sein neuer
arbeitsort new orleans die
kriminalitätsrate sind jedes jahr
dennoch
musik ist das ist das viel
dank ehrung stelle ich das ja immer das
ist was ich noch nicht ganz ehrlich ich
musste lernen dass kontrollieren und
musste fotos am tag lege
das gefahrenpotenzial ist hoch vor allem
auch weil us brechbühler nach der
ausbildung oft alleine auf patrouille
ist die familie ist sein leben
die militär und polizei dienste sind für
den gelernten polymechaniker eine
berufung
er war mit der schweizerischen
friedenstruppe im kosovo und wurde ein
experte in kampfmittelbeseitigung
entschärfung von minen und bomben
das ist einfach über den typ theologisch
mit dem haus und bin ich sehr gut in der
fach gegeben er war so gut dass er in
afghanistan blindgänger und minen im
hochgebirge und auf landwirtschafts
feldern entschärft was ist da bloß noch
ich mache meine familie
heute morgen beginnt das nächste kapitel
seiner ausbildung
er geht auf streife nun gilt es ernst
[Musik]
schlimmsten passieren nicht nur seine
hingehalten haben
[Musik]
dem gedanken seine familie nicht
wiederzusehen weiter aus kurz v begriff
verabschiedet
aha
[Musik]
habe einen kurzen
während 18 wochen lernt officer
brechbühler nun in verschiedenen
stadtbezirken sein handwerk
dienstantritt 7 uhr morgens der
lieutenant betont einmal mehr dass jede
aktion korrekt sein müsse und dass die
körper kamera jeden ihrer schritte
aufzeichnen dann wenn der dass sich uhr
spricht dazu wie viele sprachen sprechen
sie schweizerdeutsch französisch
schweizerdeutsch ist eine sprache weiter
spreche ich ein wenig russisch serbisch
kroatisch und verstehe ein wenig
spanisch
ich denke das wird genügen
[Musik]
dann geht's auf patrouille
streifenpolizisten fahren zu notrufen
brechbühler trifft seinen ausbildner
guten tag so schön wie heißt du er
arbeitet im trenchcoat wohl jeder zeit
alles passieren kann
das ist interessant am polizeiberuf mit
dem swiss bowl
der erste notruf
was hat die verdächtige person gestohlen
sie suchen eine verdächtige person die
etwas gestohlen haben soll
offiziell weiß um wen es geht
ich kenne ihn seit jahren
wenn du super aggressiv erst wird auch
er das ist meine erfahrung mit ihm und
mit vielen psychisch kranken personen
und von denen haben wir hier viele da
ist er wie geht's also ich kläre nur
einmal ab was sache ist
falls alles okay ist lassen wir dich
sofort gehen
bis dahin lege ich die hand schöne stehe
auch für mich umdrehen geht's zum stimmt
es ist keine verhaftung sondern eine
festhaltung nein verdammt sie tun wie
dein arm tut ich sehe was du meinst das
ist uns anders probieren wir lösen sie
ein wenig
officer brechbühler lernt jeden schritt
zu protokollieren
wir gehen von hier bis dorthin mit einem
mitfahrer es ist anfänglich etwas
verwirrend
der tatort der verdächtige soll hier
mehrmals für unruhe gesorgt und letzte
woche etwas gestohlen haben
die verkäuferin identifiziert es war am
donnerstag die kamera hat ihn
aufgenommen
viel aufwand für pralinen im wert von 8
dollar
sie geben ihm eine gerichtliche
vorladung und lassen ihn frei
zurück auf dem revier ein afroamerikaner
braucht hilfe im gegensatz zu anderen
us-städten scheinen rassistische
übergriffe von polizisten hier kein
zentrales thema zu sein
unterricht wird macht zur thematik wohl
vor ikonen polizeiarbeit wo man damit
übernommen nachdem österreich beurteilt
zum beispiel oder hat danach noch
nachvollziehbarer religion oder was auch
immer
sondern dass man auch nach dem urteil
es läuft außergewöhnlich wenig an seinem
ersten tag die schicht ist zu ende
und wie ist dein erster eindruck so weit
so gut
[Musik]
es verstreichen zweieinhalb monate er
wechselte ihnen andere bezirke und
bearbeitet nun viele gewaltdelikte wie
raubüberfälle schlägereien häusliche
gewalt morde
er muss den taser einsetzen und die
pistole ziehen
[Musik]
ich danke den letzten monaten relativ
viel gelernt hier auf der straße vor
augen dass ein schutz sehr sehr wichtig
ist dass es wichtig ist dass man dann
aber halt auch mal die batterien oder
maxi nach der junge max ist dass man
dass man auch unterstützt das motto
findet als nur sagte was ein guter
polizist brasilien
sein neuer ausbildner arbeitet seit 27
jahren hier
[Musik]
das wichtigste ist dass du die kultur
kennst und stehst worüber sie reden die
leute hier haben zum teil keine
ausbildung aber im leben auf der straße
sind sie geliebt als ich anfing warum
wir polizisten respektiert aber jetzt
sind die kriminellen verrückter und
schießen auf uns mehr denn je der erste
notruf
sie werden als verstärkung bei einer
schlägerei gebraucht
weil ich bilder gehen sie auf die andere
seite
startplatz
auch thomas ja ja ja ja ja ja
denken sie dass sie wirklich im
ernstfall und für person konnte stand
der angriff dass man sie wie würden sie
das dem ungarischen gute frage so klar
kann ich das nicht beantworten
aber ich würde mal sagen lässt
zusammenschluss ist davon ist rund
er wird durch innere situation oder
beruf gut siehst du bist mehr aber der
nächste notruf officer brechbühler
ermittelt ausbildner melde beobachtet es
geht um häusliche gewalt ausbildner lupo
schaut dass alles korrekt abläuft
wir sind uns einig dass er wegen
häuslicher gewalt und körperverletzung
festgenommen wird
was ist der nächste schritt
du weißt es nicht ehrlich gesagt weiß
ich nicht genau was du willst dass ich
machen soll
es geht nicht darum was ich will sondern
was das gesetz in dieser situation
verlangt
sie verstehen dass sie verhaftet sind
das ist abgefragt sie lügt ich lese
ihnen ihre rechte vor
sie haben das recht zu schweigen ab dem
lebensjahr ist das tragen von waffen
erlaubt officer brechbühler muss immer
damit rechnen dass eine gezeigt dass sie
viel aber zu sehen david edelfeder band
die wirst du was ich auch immer so heidi
weil sie massive staus und mir wurde es
nie darum schaut nur beamte ich hatte so
was mache ich zwei beamte nötig sie das
aber aufmerksam sie wachsam sie und
panik gerate und das ist hier das bild
wo der wald ist es geht schlag auf
schlag
eine person bewaffnet da ist jemand im
hinterhof ein meter ging mit einer
eisenstange auf den hausbesitzer los ist
da jemand
ich suche jemanden nach hinten gehen
wahrscheinlich ist er abgehauen ich sah
ihn früh
seine elfmonatige ausbildung ist bald zu
ende ist und dass ich bis jetzt proben
und das volk stelle aber das große ganze
also ob der beruf täglich überrascht und
aber es geht das genauso das mit
traumjob aber an allen tagen ist für ihn
am wichtigsten dass er nach dienstende
unverletzt nach hause zu seiner familie
kommen kann
[Musik]